avec nous cette semaine jean pierre
chevènement ancien ministre et
aujourd'hui président du club république
moderne bonsoir jean pierre chevènement
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez vous donc de preuves par 3 où
l'on attend vos jugements et vos
analyses également sur trois grandes
questions la première qui vous dira
peut-être droite au coeur car on connaît
vos convictions qui séduisent d'ailleurs
à gauche comme à droite la république la
république est elle en danger face à la
poussée du salafisme
c'est ce que manuel valls a dénoncé hier
soir il appelle d'ailleurs lui-même à la
reconstruction de la république
deuxième question qui vous sera posée
tout à l'heure par l'uci le malandain de
l' agence france presse au sujet de la
reconquête de l'opinion par françois
hollande s mission impossible
enfin troisième question peut-être en
forme de provocation là pour vous face à
toutes les difficultés qu'affronte la
france est ce que la solution est à
chercher du côté de l'europe
c'est ce que vous demandera tout à
l'heure mais kms de public sénat mais on
aborde d'abord tout de même le scandale
planétaire des panamas peppers est ce
que vous êtes indignés par les
révélations sur les circuits sombre de
l'argent offshore et les implications de
personnalités y compris politiques coûté
tout le monde sait douter de l'existence
des ces sociétés écrans je crois que
personne n'avait pris tout à fait
conscience de l'ampleur du problème
je vais confier quand je t'ai mis son
intérieur à arnaud montebourg et à
vincent peillon
une mission d'étude et un rapport qu'ils
m'ont remis sur les circuits de
blanchiment de l'argent sale et par
conséquent cela les avait amenés à une
tournée mondiale et un rap à me remettre
un rapport à remettre au gouvernement un
rapport qui était très intéressant alors
il y avait des propositions notamment la
transmission automatique des données
d'état à état pur et dur allemand
réprimer la fraude fiscale je me réjouis
de tout ce qui va dans le sens de la
transparence
je me réjouis aussi que la justice
française a ouvert une enquête
très vite plusieurs chef de l'état l'a
annoncée quelques heures après les
premières révélations souhaitable
cela dit je suis un peu circonspect je
suis un peu circonspect sur l'origine de
ces fuites massives 11 millions et demi
de documents ce n'est pas à la portée
d'un vulgaire à coeur 1 il faut que des
services spécialisés se soient mis au
travail à un parler de services
spécialisés bhatia oui même le kremlin
puisque je vais vous donner la réaction
hier du kremlin ou à propos de poutine
en cause du moins à travers ce nom mais
écoutez écoutez écoutez votre conduit au
kremlin parce que je trouvais avait là
un des rapprochements ram est très très
rapide
hier nous connaissons bien cette soi
disant communauté journalistique il ya
parmi eux de nombreux journalistes dont
le journalisme n'est pas l'activité
principale
beaucoup sont d'anciens employés du
département d'état de la cia d'autres
services secrets alors vous aussi vous
évoquez des services à moi je n'ai pas à
désigner le service qui est à l'origine
je vous ai dit que probablement ça
n'était pas à la portée d'un vulgaire à
coeur et je répète mon propos qu'il
fallait des services spécialisés pour
opérer la collecte de données qui
pourraient remplir 700 fois la bible oui
oui c'est un mais quand on vous dit
c'est un consortium de journaux
internationaux il me plus d'une centaine
cela permit salon wiit un bon il y a les
deux des les mêmes grilles leur sont
transmises
et puis il ya le travail que font ces
journalistes à partir quand même d'une
certaine sélection des cibles car il
faut des mots clés pour faire travailler
les ordinateurs et puis procéder à un
certain nombre de regroupements
rappelons que les cibles n'ont
évidemment pas été choisi par hasard
puisque vous évoquez le kremlin
par exemple une banque qui s'appelle la
banque rossia est désigné comme je crois
la tirelire de tous les oligarques
russes des principaux dirigeants de la
russie
donc c'est ce que dit la maison blanche
c'est un commentateur de la maison
blanche est ce que vous êtes étonnés de
l'absence par exemple d'américains dans
la liste des personnels question qu'on
ne peut que se poser
vous vous la poser oui on sait que tous
les parlementaires français et tous les
parlementaires
européens ont fait l'objet d'une enquête
tu à partir de leur nom jean pierre
chevènement il ya quand même une
indignation en voulant temps où
d'entendre qu'on n'entend pas tellement
et je suis aussi et on défend et on
défend tous les hadjis glados
ah oui comme tous les 21 juin mais il ya
très longtemps que je suis indignée que
oui parce que je sais à la différence de
beaucoup qui semblent le découvrir que
c'est comme cela que ça marche et que en
effet les gens qui disposent des moyens
financiers colossaux comme nous le
savons 1 1% de la planète détient une
fortune comparable aux 99 cents reste on
vient on sait que naturellement il sera
alors pour eux évoqué vivons cachés ce
n'est pas une découverte
bien sûr c'était un axiome wild à
l'industriel pensez vous évoquez bon le
rôle de certains services alors que
certains dans cette affaire est
d'ailleurs la plupart des gens défendent
le rôle des lanceurs d'alerté
vous vous êtes sceptique sur ce que vous
n'êtes pas lance une alerte par hasard
j'irai pour pouvoir lancer une alerte
faut avoir accès à des données
extrêmement vaste alors ça servi alors
que selon vous si je suis votre
réflexion et vous savez j'ai regardé
attentivement ce qui était dit dans les
colonnes du journal le monde
plus lire qu'il y à beaucoup
d'approximations on nous parle d'une
station de ski avec ses pistes à une
heure de route de saint pétersbourg
moi je voulais un peu la russie
effectivement puisque j'ai une mission
mercury
c'est très plat vous savez au tour de
saint pétersbourg je ne vois pas où
peut-être cette station de ski
j'ajoute que ce sont des proches se sont
c'est pas les dirigeants qui sont
nommément mis en cause ce sont des
proches
quel lien on peut le supposer on ne
découvre pas que l'urss a disparu que la
russie est un pays capitaliste que les
gens qui sont désignés comme étant les
oligarques la nouvelle bourgeoisie
ce sont des gens qui ont fait main basse
sur les richesses qui était celle de
l'union soviétique jadis donc